cinq soldats français de la force
intérimaire des nations unies blessé
hier soir au sud liban à paris le chef
présumé des farl georges ibrahim
abdallah transféré à la prison de la
santé et au palais de l'elysée le
président mitterrand reçoit le patron
des services secrets le général un bout
l'histoire d'un détenu en cavale qui
réussit sa réinsertion mais retourne en
prison pour finir sa peine c'est le
reportage d'antenne 2 de fantoches
chantait et roger mas sport automobile
ayrton senna en première position pour
le grand prix du portugal demain devant
monde sait les prost et puis au bol d'or
motocycliste sarre ont jusqu'à présent
en fait nous sommes le samedi 20
septembre 1986 cela fait 547 jours de
détention pour marcel carton et marcel
fontaine 486 jours de détention pour
jean paul kauffmann et michel seurat 196
jours de détention
pour aurel cornéa jean louis normandin
d'antenne 2 et 136 jours de détention
pour camille sonntag il reste sept
otages français détenus au liban
bonsoir alors que la france demandait
hier soir au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu à new york de prendre ses
responsabilités et d'agir pour que dans
des délais brefs la force des nations
unies au liban la finul se déploie
jusqu'à la frontière libano israélienne
cinq casques bleus français ont été
blessés par l'explosion d'une roquette
au sud liban
deux de ses militaires seraient
gravement blessé commentaires philippe
gassot les dernières victimes en date
sont à nouveau française cinq soldats
ont été blessés dans ce camp par un tir
de roquette en un mois quatre français
sont morts et 30 ont été blessés pour
paris ce n'est plus supportable
déjà la france avait demandé que l'onu
prenne ses responsabilités réponse sans
doute demain l'émissaire français a
proposé lui une solution si l'on veut
que la finul puisse à nouveau disposé du
concours entiers de la population
libanaise
il faut que cette force puisse dans les
délais les plus brefs se déployer comme
il était prévu en 1978 sur la frontière
internationale m l'installation de la
finul sur la frontière israélienne s'est
demandé à gérer
alem d'abandonner la zone tampon
contrôlée par la ls un voeu exprimé
également par le secrétaire général de
l'onu monsieur perez de cuellar
les etats unis ont émis des réserves et
ont tenu à préciser que ce ne sont pas
les soldats israéliens qui tire sur la
finul la france et l'onu se trompe de
cible pour les israéliens qui ont
renforcé ces dernières heures leurs
positions dans le sud du liban
il n'est pas question de lever le camp
on ne veut pas être à jérusalem ni
victime ni bouc émissaire il est donc de
fait que la force intérimaire des
nations unies ne s'est jamais pleinement
déployée au sud liban et que de
nombreuses positions tenues par le
contingent français sont très exposés
pierre serra tente maintenant
d'expliquer la répartition des forces
dans le sud libanais voici comment se
répartissent sur le terrain les forces
en présence au liban sud en jaune en bas
de la carte la zone tampon envers la
zone dans laquelle sont déployés les
différentes contingents de la finul les
français sont installés notamment à
marrakech
à côté des voyages et c'est dans cette
région qu'ont eu lieu les incidents
meurtriers de ces dernières semaines et
mission difficile pour les casques bleus
leur mandat prévoit en effet qu ils
doivent empêcher aussi bien les
incursions israéliennes dans le pays
pour des représailles aux que les
infiltrations possible de co bordeaux
libanais ou palestiniens venus du nord
une force internationale en somme des
nations unies qui est prise entre deux
feux entre les extrémistes musulmans
libanais qui veulent en découdre avec
israël et la zone tampon au sud
cette zone tampon suit les contours de
la frontière elle est d'une profondeur
variable entre 20 et 30 km par endroits
elle est principalement peuplé de
chiites mais aussi de chrétiens et les
israël à contrôle quasi intégralement
gràce à l'armée du liban sud d'abord
forte de 2000 hommes armés équipés
entraînés et payé par israël cette armée
est commandée par un général chrétien à
la retraite
antoine lahad y siègent à metulla ses
moyens d'action les renseignements dont
ils disposent et même ses ordres
viennent eux aussi israël et les
israéliens sont donc les maîtres de
cette région
arguant qu'ils ne veulent en aucun cas
se retrouver dans la situation qui selon
re avait motivé la guerre de 82 il
affirme que le seul moyen de garantir la
paix dans leurs provinces du nord la
galilée et de maintenir sous leur
contrôle
cette zone tampon au liban il refuse en
conséquence d'appliquer la résolution
des nations unies qui prévoit le retrait
sur la frontière internationale
libano-israélienne à beyrouth est dans
le couvent de yarzé 300 personnes
assistaient cet après-midi un service
religieux donné à la mémoire de
l'attaché militaire français de
l'ambassade de france le colonel
christian gouttière assassiné jeudi le
président libanais aminé gemayel a
décoré à titre posthume le colonel
gouttière le président du parlement est
le premier du liban étaient représentés
à l'appel des principales forces
politiques chrétienne beyrouth est et sa
banlieue ont observé une grève de
protestation après cet assassinat
aujourd'hui dans cette même capitale du
liban le comité de solidarité avec les
prisonniers politiques arabes et du
proche orient le cfppa a renouvelé ses
menaces à l'adresse de la france
nous n'avons pas mis un terme à nos
opérations et nous n'avons pas
l'intention de le faire
d'autre part l'une des neuf personnes
recherchées par la police française
caroline sbr el bitar a démenti à
beyrouth être impliqué dans ces
attentats affirmant ne pas avoir quitté
son village depuis la mi juillet à paris
georges ibrahim abdallah le chef présumé
des fractions armées révolutionnaires
libanaises les farl a été transféré de
fleury mérogis à la prison de la santé
officiellement pour des raisons de
sécurité nouvelle réunion du conseil de
sécurité intérieure avec jacques chirac
ce matin et puis il ya une heure au
palais de l'elysée le président de la
république recevait le ministre de la
défense monsieur henri giraud et puis le
directeur de la dgse les services
secrets le général un beau après
monsieur giraud l'arrivée du général un
beau à l'elysée il y à quelques dizaines
de minutes également ont fait l'après
midi à metz déclarations de charles
fresco à une seule phrase de charles
pasqua
les enquêtes sont en cours je crois que
nous avançons a dit le ministre de
l'intérieur à propos des enquêtes sur le
terrorisme devant les membres de l'union
des français de l'étranger jacques
chirac elle soulignait la détermination
de la france face au terrorisme et au
problème des otages
une détermination qui se retrouvent dans
un sondage publiés demain par le journal
du dimanche sondage ipsos une très large
majorité des parisiens interrogés
s'il reste vigilant n'ont pas renoncé à
leur projet de fin de semaine des
opinions que nous avons vérifié avec
patrice volée et nicolas jacobs
les parisiens ont profité du soleil et
des terrasses cet après midi pourtant
depuis quelques jours ils évitent les
lieux publics les plus connus moins de
monde dans les galeries marchandes 30 %
de spectateurs en moins dans les salles
de cinéma est un désert cet après midi
sur les champs elysées 7 10 personnes
depuis hier
je vous dise à chaque séance quand même
très peu
moi je me trouverai soir les gens ils
n'entraient pas et ils ont raison
combien ouvert en moins à peu près je
fais trop le raisin que notre langue
fourche en bois
malgré les mesures de sécurité les
clients évitent les grands magasins
résultat une baisse d'environ 10% des
chiffres d'affaires en une semaine les
parisiens préfèrent leur quartier et
modifie quelque peu leur façon de vivre
dans un endroit très fréquenté
vous iriez sur les grands boulevards
aujourd'hui non non c'est mon temps
prestement de quartier puis j'habite rue
du commerce donc là je me sens en
sécurité j'ai peut-être tort d'ailleurs
j'ai quand même un peu attention je n'ai
peut-être pas dans les grands magasins
mettant les noubas saint germain dans
les boutiques dans les petites boutiques
je pense que j'ai des parisiens rassurés
malgré tout par les mesures de sécurité
prises dans les lieux publics
beaucoup de travail pour les sociétés de
surveillance il faut compter environ 20%
de
de plus de chiffre d'affaires par mois
environ ça va se traduire par ça nous
signons en train des contrats par jour
actuellement
ce qu'ils nient ce qui signifie une mise
en place d'une dizaine de personnes par
jour le nouveau personnage
bon alors on puisse dans leur réserve
bien sûr parce qu'on est là toute une
liste de gens qui on est en attente du
blé qui sont des chômeurs en lambeaux ce
pari était calme cet après midi des
promeneurs prudent mais semble si cause
apparente des attentes un second sondage
publié également par le journal du
dimanche et un baromètre politique
françois mitterrand et jacques chirac
sont à la au 57 % de satisfaits pour le
chef de l'état 30 % de mécontents 47%
d'opinions favorables pour monsieur
chirac contre 38 % de mécontents
c'est la pleine période d'activité pour
les viticulteurs les vendanges sont
largement commencé en beaujolais
bourgogne pour le muscadet pour les vins
du midi
la récolte 86 sera abondante et de bonne
qualité mais les producteurs sont très
inquiets car la distillation est très
menacée par les règlements européens
explications avec le reportage dans le
département de l'hérault de maryse mano
gérard des relais cette année janvier
aura la quantité et la qualité
et pourtant il est inquiet inquiet parce
que bruxelles trouvent les vendanges
trop bonne et rechignent de plus en plus
à distiller les excédents l'an dernier
le quart de la récolte française a pris
le chemin des alambics malgré les vignes
arrachées résultats bruxelles baisse les
prix à la distillation et c'est autant
de moins pour la recette des
viticulteurs si une partie de cette
recette mais supprimée quelle va être la
norme en réflexion et de mon réflexe a
va être le passé à 110 ha ha sam 25 30
et même plus c'est possible pourquoi
parce que même si je le vend deux fois
mais cher et si je me débrouille pour
travailler moins cher un désherbant
laissant des têtes par tout à fait ne
faisant pas le travail correctement
comme on doit le faire et bien je ferai
la même recette
résultat il y aura une mère de vin qui
va être sur le marché qui sera vendu à
des prix dérisoires et qui donne dans la
qualité ne sera pas
garantis par les producteurs la colère
des producteurs prise au piège bruxelles
s'en moque
son calcul est simple pour chaque acte
litres d'alcool pur exprès des excédents
elle verse encore 190 francs soit deux
fois moins qu'il ya six ans à ce tarif
beaucoup de distillerie font faillite
mais celle qui reste à vous que l'alcool
viticole est invendable
nous sommes en concurrence et puisque
nous avons perdu un tas de marché
d'alcool noble que nous opérions qui
rentrait dans la fabrication de certains
lots et qui sont fait maintenant avec
des alcools agricole également mais je
n'ai hélas ou de sucreries l' alcool de
betterave est en moins cher les stops
d'alcool viticole s'accumulent la
communauté a voulu les brader à 70
francs l'hectolitre
elle n'a pas trouvé preneur un constat
qui ne peut que l'encourager à supprimer
la distillation certains responsables
viticoles l'ont compris et réclament un
délai si par hasard les priorités là
s'est arrêtée brusquement les culés prix
de soutien les distillation de
soutiennent était brusquement supprimer
ce serait réellement un désastre
économique pour cette région
si les choses se fasse en douceur c'est
à dire avec un désengagement progressif
cette région aura le temps de recueillir
les fruits des efforts de qualité qui
ont été faits
même progressive la suppression de la
distillation dans le midi ne se fera pas
sans heurts et c'est compréhensible
pendant des années elle a été le pilier
de l'économie viticole il y a un peu
plus de 46 mille détenus en france
contrairement aux rumeurs très peu
utilisent les rares permission de sortie
pour partir en cavale
quelques-uns ne rentre pas l'histoire
qui suit est celle de jean yves beck
il n'était pas rentré après sa
permission il a usé de ce temps de
liberté pour se réinsérer
puis il a décidé de retourner en prison
reportage françoise son père et roger
motte quelques vêtements dans un sac de
sport
le strict minimum jean yves beck un
détenu en cavale depuis 18 mois se
prépare un étrange voyage
en fait jamais si le plus dur c'est pour
ceux d'un pas décidé
jean et baic va se constituer prisonnier
il a choisi de franchir la porte de ce
tribunal de décliner son identité pour
mettre un terme à 18 mois de cavale
j'ai connu la prison d'aix avant mon
procès de cour d'assises et je vais dire
qu'à l'intérieur c'est vraiment
ça reflète bien la misère moraliser un
car sera là et
on a l'impression
2 j'ai l'impression moi personnellement
de rentrée
carrément
en faire quoi il n'y a pas beaucoup
condamné à l'âge de 18 ans pour un homme
armé puis pour proxénétisme
jean yves beck a déjà passé dix sept ans
de sa vie derrière les barreaux à sa
6ème permission de sortie il craque n'a
pas la force de rentrer en prison
lorsque on prend la décision de ne pas
rentrer encore une fois c'est une
décision qu'on prend armand on se met en
marche employant l'expression en est en
cavale
le mode de vie en cavale implique
pratiquement
une récidive qui est inéluctable orbec
lui associe d'exceptionnel c'est que
tout en étant dans une situation
marginale
il a mené une vie normale il est resté
avec sa compagne avec l'enfant de celle
ci a dans des conditions très difficiles
il a trouvé des gens qui l'ont aidé et
qui l'ont épaulé et de lui même et
aujourd'hui encore une fois dans des
conditions exceptionnellement difficile
il sert et adapté à la liberté
les derniers rayons de soleil avant de
retrouver les murs de sa cellule peut
être vingt mois peut être plus c'est le
prix qu'il devra payer pour être un
homme libre
et pour prouver que sa réinsertion dans
la société est possible
je suis rentré en prison que j'avais 18
ans j'étais condamné une première fois à
15 ans de réclusion criminelle et je
laissais 12 mai pour se débarrasser de
12 ans de prison en se débarrassant
comme ça on a besoin d'affection on a
besoin d'eux d'être entouré et bon ben
moi j'ai pas trouvé ça je suis sorti
avec mes valises devant la porte il ya
les personnes
si je dois faire encore disons presque
20 mois c'est pour la bonne cause
pour moi je me dis quoi qu'il en soit si
on me relâche tout de suite ou que je
fasse est à moi ce qui me tient ses les
amis sont morts c'est la femme qui
m'attend et j'ai jusqu'au bout le projet
essentiel c'est un vivre ensemble puis
enfin moi surtout pour moi de commencer
à vivre encore réellement jeu sera en
fait ma première année quoi mardi matin
des dieux passé inaperçu devant le
tribunal d'aix-en-provence
jean yves beck est rentré seul parce
qu'il a choisi de son plein gré de payer
sa dette
sport sur le circuit du castellet depuis
cet après-midi ce tissu de l'épreuve du
bol d'or motocycliste est peut-être
suivi le départ du bol d'or en direct
sur antenne 2 heures au début les fera
sa rançon bien comportés puisqu'ils
étaient rebondissements début de course
pour l'instant c'est l'équipage farrow
ball et battistini qui est en tête sur
honda je viens de l'apprendre brigitte
duvauchelle va faire le point après
quelques heures de course
15 heures départ du 50e bol d'or les
quatre la motta et l'enfant courant pour
enfourcher leurs propres tubes dominique
sarron sur honda prend tout de suite la
tête de course
- bon départ face à christian soit y en
a qui réussit quand même l'exploit de
remonter de la 15e à la troisième place
puis à 17h coup de théâtre alors qu'il
était en deuxième position j'ai un coup
de massue il ramène sa moto en courant
avant de s'effondrer
la moto est très endommagé les
mécaniciens me reviennent vers à
dimanche figurent pièces dans le
carburateur
mais cette allégresse à lui de retour
avec audi dont l'autre équipier patrick
bigras n'est pas pour très longtemps
quelques instants après nouveau coup dur
pour la honda numéro 1 au top
ils viennent de condamner d'aminé
ailleurs la numéro 2 ou encore l'abandon
après sa refonte de course aux deux
premières places à la lui les deux
frères farro et puis demain il y aura le
grand prix du portugal automobile de
formule 1 il y aura 26 concurrents au
départ et après les séances d'essais
c'est le brésilien ayrton senna qui
partira en première ligne en pole
position le voici
et puis derrière lui derrière national
britannique nigel mansell et puis
derrière mansell entre les positions
alain prost c'est la septième pole
position d'ayrton senna pour cette
saison du championnat du monde
automobile
voilà la proposition sénat mansell prost
burger fabi piquette je crois que
arnould et 10e temps après ces essais
pour donc le grand prix du portugal
demain à history cyclisme ce soir à
colorado springs aux états unis la
française jeannie longo s'attaque au
record du monde de l'heure la météo
n'est guère favorable à la tentative de
la double championne du monde
tennis henri leconte poursuit sa série
de bonnes performances après sa victoire
d'un tonneau de genève henri leconte
s'est qualifié pour la finale du tournoi
de hambourg il est ici au fond du court
ou regarder comment il conclu
victorieusement face à l'espagnol emilio
sanchez par un beau coup droit bas en
deux sets cette demi-finale et en finale
henry le ton front froid
le finaliste de washington le
tchécoslovaque mais si le pmu va
poursuivre l'informatisation de ses
bureaux le traitement des paris ce sera
plus efficace et plus simple pour les
services du pmu voyez le reportage de
pierre et bresse et roger mathurin le
pmu a gagné son pari
tout d'abord reconvertir ses 3 600
collaborateurs en les initiant au
maniement du système informatisé de prix
les enjeux et ensuite satisfaire et ce
fils qui ont ainsi plus de facilités
pour jouer puisque il leur suffit de
cocher les numéros choisis sur une
simple carte informatique
alors le jeu saint-aignan procès vous
arrivez à comprendre quelque chose à
cette pression de jouer madame père
s'appelait critique avec les parcs se
jouera jamais je me dis alors savourer
ce nouveau système et lorient désormais
manche est très pratique il n'ya pas
d'erreur possible
les clients sont satisfaits et par
rapport à l'ancien système on a le temps
que j'utilisais des pouvoirs de regarder
un petit bec degré aura mieux échanger
quelques mots
alors je regarde paris avec les
ordinateurs ça marche
alors dès l'année prochaine les
personnes qui préfèrent rester chez
elles pourront réaliser leurs paris sur
milices tél mais en attendant les enjeux
des différents fragments pmu sont
recensés par l'ordinateur régionales se
savent aux régionales qui qui me récolte
tous les paris qu'ils ont été
enregistrés ce matin dans la région de
mantes la jolie à une heure exactement
le l'ordinateur va déclencher l'appel de
tous les points de vente rattaché cet
ordinateur et nous allons récolter tous
les paris qui était enregistrée ce matin
dans ses composantes dans toute la
france est organisée de cette manière
maintenant
pas tout à fait le sommes actuellement à
peu près au tir de notre informatisation
nous aurons bientôt 25 centres
informatiques avec son ordinateur qu'il
au top et 10000 terminaux qui alors il
va dire c'est aujourd'hui à evry 17 10 1
je vous en prie pierrette voici les
rapports ça donne 17 10 5 4554 francs et
810 pendant un an différents le tout
pour 5 francs je crois que notre
confrère le faire c'est magazine be
brave au pire être fait un peu familier
pour vous dans ton avis paris vous êtes
en forme vous donner les tiercés
successifs en ce moment oui ça marche
cela renvoie pour demain dans le prix
paris turf c'est ça oui c'est le prix de
notre confrère paris turf alors il
s'autorise une course qui s'impliquent
et ce après qu'il s'appelait le prix de
bellevue j'ai trouvé là où ses
concurrents
alors il s'agit d'une course à handicap
longue de 2200 mètres qui s'adresse aux
pouliches
elles sont âgées de 3 ans et plus si
vous savez qu'à cette époque ci de
l'année les polices sont en super forme
elle ne sont pas sous influence de leur
sexe comme on dit au printemps
tout devrait bien se passer il n'y a pas
vraiment une favorite qui se dégage de
ce look est très très bon et homogène et
parmi les vingt concurrents engagés dans
cette course et bien voici maintenant la
sélection que je vous propose dans mon
pronostic avec tout d'abord roberto
splinter le numéro 1 monté par le
nouveau jour qu'américain georges et
velasquez ensuite talitha le numéro 17
qui lui a été confié qu'ils et elles
tutoient été confiée au jeune et
talentueux eric saint-martin et puis
ensuite conteste un numéro 12
ce qui a été préparé à dorine en vue de
ce tiercé et puis ensuite je pense qu'on
va faire confiance à ce my beauty le mur
11 pas tenait le numéro 16 d'autres
music halle 6 sollicitude le 15 et
s'amouracher le numéro 3 1 17 12 11 16 6
15 et 3 pour terminer merci direct
nathalie baye de nouveau sur une scène
de théâtre ce sera au théâtre de
l'atelier à partir de ce soir dans le
xviiie arrondissement à paris nathalie
baye est l'une des interprètes de la
pièce de natalia ginzburg adriana monty
c'est le lait bellon qui a adapté cette
oeuvre et nathalie va y retrouve le
théâtre pour un personnage qui se posent
des questions qui change beaucoup
d'humeur et kiri reportage nicole cornu
langlois et frédérick basile entre cette
solitude angoissante
avant le spectacle et le bonheur intense
des applaudissements c'est grâce à la
magie du pièce de théâtre la remise en
question choisi délibérément par une
star de cinéma
pour ces retrouvailles exploité par la
presse comme un événement la thalie by a
comme partenaire patrick chesnais le
mari et micheline presle catherine
arditi françoise mégane une joyeuse
fanning un peu bohème
c'est une pièce qui m'a touché kim amour
qui est resté comme ça dans j'ai pas dit
oui tout de suite je les lui que les
restes et les rafles dans ma tête dans
mon coeur j'avais envie de la jouer sans
réfléchir je réfléchis mois mais pas le
second défi l'ultra mais l'infection
l'audio et des siècles une réfection
d'une petite seconde et joie en clair
lucide que non
les raisons d'une seconde l'affection
les étables réflexion juste utile sont
celles qu'on porte en soi pendant des
mois des paninis carlo kutwa de la
flexion de jambes à moi jamais je n'ai
jamais fait un carton à fléchir et c'est
vraiment une comédie et puis un nul ya
un langage est un univers que j'aime
énormément et je trouve le personnage
adriana est un personnage formidable
pour une comédienne parce qu'il ya plein
de choses différentes à jouer c'est
tendre drôle et des moments comme ça qui
dérape qui sont un peu d'angoissé les
moments violents ont des moments agaçant
on est maman
c'est pas trés pas souvent des rôles
comme ça dans
en tout cas au cinéma puis quand j'ai
commencé mon métier j'ai alterné théâtre
cinéma je voudrais pouvoir le
recommencez alterné pas resté six ans
d'écart nouveau sens sans monter sur
scène pas si tu es aussi au théâtre elle
retrouve ce plaisir immédiat du contact
avec le public
un théâtre qu'elle retrouvera désormais
chaque soir pendant deux mois et dans
quelques minutes sur antenne 2 on
retrouve michel drucker bonsoir michel
je crois que vous êtes en direct avec
nos wii au bar de champs elysées en
train de naître déjà du champagne
oui oui ma part il faut dire qu'on va
parler du film nuits d'ivresse alors
nous sommes déjà sommes déjà dans le
bain avec josiane balasko et et thierry
lhermitte qui sont deux des piliers de
l'émission ce soir si thierry lhermitte
est un petit peu rougeau de mines
vous comprendrez pourquoi tout à l'heure
il est trop maquillée et j'ai pas qu'il
est trop maquillée mais je crois qu'il
est pas tout à fait dans son état normal
car il a décidé d'arriver dans un état
d'ébriété assez avancé bon je ne vous
dis que ça bon michel une nouvelle
formule de champs elysées ou la même
équipe avec françoise coquet et tout
tous les habitués la même équipe partant
du principe que les mode se démode très
vite on a choisi de rester classique et
oui donc je serai habillé et y aura pas
de piscine on plongera pas et les gens
sont très corrects sur eux très bien
propre et nous aurons tous ceux qui font
l'actualité cinéma théâtre la chanson
est un peu plus de visites international
l'année luigi samedi prochain et puis
larry hagman entre autres avec linda
gray c'est-à-dire sue ellen et jr dans
15 jours je ne vous dis que ça et puis
ce soir bien guy bedos tous ceux qui
font l'actualité et tous les tubes qui
ont fait danser les français et leurs
parents cet été en groupe et l'activité
de michel drucker c'est un petit peu
ralenti vous faites moins de choses pour
uniquement réservé pour antenne 2 et
champs elysées absolument en exclusivité
sur cette chaîne que j'aime profondément
et et c'est nantais et c'est thierry
lhermitte qui m'a conseillé de lever un
petit peu le pied c'est à dire le
travail et 18 heures par jour je ne
trouvais plus que 17h30 j'oserais dire
que l'ère de lever plus vite le verre de
champagne que le pied comme on vit merci
mon p'tit claude au revoir au revoir
bonne de fin de soirée sur un thème peu
sur antenne à la suite j ce soir vers
minuit on aura un ex utilité avec prins
dans les enfants du rock est pour
l'instant trouve la météo alain chaufour
et bien clos de ce soir on peut on peut
dire biz puisque demain le temps sera
pratiquement le même qu'aujourd'hui si
ce n'est qu'il sera encore plus beau
encore plus beau pour les régions qui
aujourd'hui
n'ont pas bénéficié d'un soleil sur
pendant toute la journée alors regardez
bien la photo satellite prise cet après
midi vers 12h30 heure du soleil 14h30
heure locale donc l'anticyclone placés
sur les îles britanniques et bien
protège toujours le pays et empêche les
perturbations sur le même scénario
d'arriver sur le territoire français
alors la concrétisation sur la carte du
temps prévu pour demain voilà c'est le
soleil qui rayonne partout l'ouest l'est
le nord le sud ouest également à noter
quand même des passages nuageux assez
importants sur le golfe du lion pyrénées
orientales golfe du lion et puis
également sur le sud-est sur la côte
d'azur et sur la corse où là il ya des
risques d'averses orageuses pour l'après
midi demain pour la fin de la soirée
tout comme d'ailleurs sur ce le golfe du
lion côté température et bien il fait
toujours beau toujours chaud regardez
bien de 16 ici à cherbourg jusqu'à 20 à
mulhouse c'est pour la partie nord et
pour le sud toujours chaud 22 ici à
limoges jusqu'à 28 en corse
demain c'est le dimanche 21 septembre
le soleil se lève à 7h36 se couche à
19h50 et donc trois minutes de soleil en
moins et nous fêterons les mathieu et
bien voilà pour le dernier journal
d'antenne 2 ce sera bien un pradines au
kivu le présentera ce sera à 23h40 à
demain 20h bonsoir merci